ciao ciao a tutti benvenuti
guardate un po come stiamo
allora io sono un bambino aveva
improvvisato qualcosa è una sorta di
frankenstein zombie è uscito dalla
galera ma questi che questa maglietta
con questa maglietta al video di can't
nell'altro la palla al piede ha salutato
mentre la mia trasformazione in immobili
o completa anche col costume con i denti
da vampiro i nostri figli di iscrizione
e alla fine di questo video
ma oggi andiamo a fare leggi che
facciamo già bus giallo
andiamo per la zucca e alla mia del
video potrete votare quale zuccheri che
suda di più da quella di vitale per il
cinema perché voglio fare uno zucchero e
spaventa le persone
vediamo potete programmo allora io
l'abbiamo sempre fatto una zucca ero
alle elementari la prima e unica volta
io non lo sono un po meno
io l'ho mai fatto ha preso a 20 m
lacrime l'ho fatta
ma continuo la mia maestra perché allora
tutti e stiamo bene fra l'altro le
uniche studi dobbiamo trovarci saltasse
zucca la zucca è brutto ma scusate sono
forti e hanno tipo dei brufoli non
verificate che i produttori che andò
male la zucca deve essere brutta perché
sono la zucca di halloween bella non fa
paura in giro da voi la farete la zucca
quest'anno se si come e se volete
mandarci la foto grande osate l'asta
ghani castori se così possiamo vedere
allora iniziamo subito che mi provo a
saggiare tagliare questo grana padano a
casa se siete piccolini non faceva casa
fatevi aiutare dai genitori da te in
questo video ci mancheranno dieci dita
due braccia sappiamo che realizzerà per
le zucche oppure cittadina ma noi
abbiamo pianto mercato è veramente un
figlio di halloween più pubblico di
quanto pensassi questa è la mia zucca
per anno vibranti giorno ho paura che il
coltello stava aiuto io sto già stato
qua
evviva
questi sono insieme perché vedete un po
saprete già mi stimava tanto cadendo
però interessante magari si riesce a
stare in banca prato se facciamo di
pomodori una veduta di tutto ma volete
un po di temi lì da vent'anni
cervello e siamo riusciti a buttarla
mette decisamente la parte più faticosa
l'abbiamo pulita più o meno bene dai
serbi hanno poi questa è la mia e questa
è la mia quindi l'abbiamo chiamata per
bene e allora la parte più divertente
dobbiamo fare il disegno scegli allora
io sto con compilando col disegno ok io
ammette un personaggio che ho preferito
anche telefonato temibile di zucche
prologo di un parco di perché crede
troppo bello mondo cos'è un personaggio
disney sembra legato alla fazione il
disegno è supposto orto farò indovinate
chi è forse avete capito già chi è
se si vede non si vede niente
ma sono un altro occhio da per l'andrea
parte reveal the move ed è ormai invero
molto bello vediamo qui invece come vado
io
io già ho fatto il disegnino e adesso ho
già fatto il primo occhio ovviamente lo
devo ancora lo devo ancora come si dice
dovi finaniani definire bene e questo è
il mio disegno ad essere riuscito a fare
anche un occhio finora è un pezzo di
nato un po storta cercando di fare
l'altro chi ma attenta con quel coltello
fi piano
non è più difficile di quanto sembra io
invece come scommesso che io sto buon
punto ho fatto il irruzioni il nasino e
adesso la bocca per un altro tempo la
tutto mi sta mangiando il coltello non
vuole tempo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tale mi sta aiutando a fare la bocca
perché è veramente inizi le fare la
bocca come sta andando
zombie mio potete scegliere un disegno
più facili effettivamente un po
complicata la bocca invece quella
digitale quasi pronta dopo tiriamo fuori
numero che rappresenta proprio questa la
giacca perché allegra simpatica fa paura
a nessuno si vede ma piano piano prima
fa le incisioni col coltello notare il
mio disegno tutto storto l'ho dovuto
cancellare e rifare perché la bocca era
tutta storta
povero povero zombie faccio differenza
per l'aviazione ad essere troppo
complicata la cambia ritorno i denti
entriamo dentro una zucca visti
attraverso gli occhi della zucca 80 83
allora grazia vitale siamo riusciti a
fare la borgata configurarle allora
tiriamola fuori
che bello non so perché ma è molto
[Musica]
rilassante soddisfacente spinge dentro
giorgio pezzi di lego bellissimo
inquietantissimo il sorriso e un po
storto ma vabbè quasi ostentato è vero
il mandiamo credente e vari finita un
pochettino però mi piace un sacco non
vedo l'ora di vederla con la candela
tra un po quella digitale e super
sorridente super allegra lungo e
bellissimo vedere diavoleria scattando
ostentava artico quattro denti in tutto
cinque sorridendo perché rallegra perché
una zucca allegra come la famiglia che i
cani sono adesso la rifiniamo un po e
poi mettiamo le candele allora ecco con
le nostre zucchette ultimo è fortissimo
la mia voglia cui tante anche allora
proveremo sia nella classica candela ora
ne abbiamo solo da e proveremo anche
quando delle luci colorate così vediamo
diversi effetti siete pronti a vedere
l'effetto che le voci bianche ma sembra
visse una delle candele comune è troppo
simpatica la sola zucchetta sopra
sorridente che carina che somiglia che
ne pensate vi piace troverà non
attendiamo tutte le consistono questa
per ora pertanto dobbiamo respingere lo
tra poco quindi se facciamo mettere la
candela 3 2 1 con la candela alla mia
diventato grossa si rosso sangue tipo
fry moneti puglia mi è molto 5 parte
penso guardate che cattivo però ancora
capito è jack skelton non so se si
riconosce perché un po sordo nuovo jack
skeleton e con tanti flop
e tu cosa dentro su come questo sorrido
spuntata io sono il re di halloween e tu
che fai è normalissimo attimo anche i
denti con interessi netti parlando un
cucchiaio che ti mando i buchi ai due
per chiudendo tutto è proprio uguale a
te cosa giusta
allora qual è inquietante secondo voi la
mia jack skeleton e tu critichi la mia è
pronto dopo zucca punto la sua honda
zucca porta presentata in effetti le
fatto segno chi storti pochino non
tantissimo la simpatica perché non
mangia niente con la bocca grande asta
in un bacino allora ora chiudiamo queste
cucine e mettiamo pelle rosa vediamo che
se to fakie angkor corsini accettiamo
quando non si vede niente
chiediamo 31 quando ero ad una vasta una
rosa ma sono bellissime
significativa la via è veramente hinkle
italia la tua è cattiva e sta per
renderle che sono jack che per il rete
che mi dissi costo maggiore
gli appaiono una zucca ora questo già lo
sapeva che per che cosa vi piace di più
quella bianca o questa è troppo bella ma
presentiamo un cretino che stecca invece
è come fare la storia carino
la adoro perché stai tutto il tempo al
buio primi la zucca certo troppo belle
io voglio che il mio z confisca zucca
con cappotto allora mi lascio questo
andazzo quotate
se vi piace anche la mia zucca jack
skeleton storto o la mia zucca con foto
fateci sapere anche nei commenti di
timestamp del momento che mi ha fatto
più ridere o del momento che mi piacete
di più che ne andiamo sempre a riveder
se li è fatti si sa perché altri video
vorreste vedere altre creazioni che
vorreste che facciamo al tema mandateci
le vostre foto della zucca ap con la
standiana in the stories storie e
sterili e ora mi lasciano qua 4
cartelline su cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite
buona visione